technology reaching new dimensions this
morning a hologram company
is in town showcasing its haliportation
machine it's called portal
uses a small studio setup to beam your
image
anywhere in the world it's so crazy
hector mejia live with
more on this and a demonstration hey
hector good morning
yeah hey there alex good morning earlier
we showed you that setup you just talked
about now we're getting up close and
personal with the machine this
is the portal machine and you see
there's nothing in it right now but in
just
a second the inventor and ceo david
nutzbaum is about to appear
as he steps into the setup to taco there
he is to talk to us well
hello there hello hello hello hello
hector uh good seeing you
thanks for having me thanks for talking
to us which planet are you coming to us
from
oh uh well this is the planet mars
thank you for having me well thanks for
having us so you know the point is
you step into the setup and you can be
anywhere in the world and interact with
people this way is that right
yeah you could be anywhere in the world
and using the power of portal you can
beam
from wherever you are to wherever you
need to be in real time
with the ability to completely interact
with your audience
so before we talk about how we can see
this here all across las vegas at casino
sports venues you name it
how does this even work it's a real
human sized
machine this is a seven foot tall
uh four and a half foot wide two foot
deep hollow portation device
so anywhere there's a portal uh any
person could beam into the portal from
wherever they are in real time
so how can this uh change up
entertainment as we know it here in town
um imagine a comedian or any entertainer
uh
imagine uh any uh inspirational speaker
or religious leader anybody who needs to
be
in more than one place at a time could
beam howard stern could beam out of his
uh out of his basement into hundreds
thousands of locations at the exact same
time
david and you were sharing with me uh
some pretty cool examples you guys have
already used this in entertainment
on the red carpet at the emmys some
major concerts tell us a little bit
about that
uh kane brown recently beamed from
nashville where he was uh he was stuck
in nashville
coronavirus is happening and you know
what can i tell you he needed to be in
hollywood for
the uh i heart music festival so we
beamed him there
in real time and he performed along with
uh
swaylee and khalid for a trio that could
have only happened through the power of
portal
sounds exciting exciting we have a lot
more to talk about but uh you know we're
gonna
high five here from a distance or
facebook
high five i don't know i don't know
technology
so there you go we'll be back in a few
minutes to talk a bit more about the
plans to roll this out here across
town for now reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you guys
that is so crazy all right hector well
thank you we'll have to
hop in there and pretend like we're
somewhere else too